[Music]
what's going on and welcome to an
overview of the lenovo p9 20 data
science workstation what you see in
front of you is the flagship version
which comes with all sorts of goodies so
inside of here
well what do we get inside of here so as
soon as this thing arrived at my door
and I got it out of the box the very
first thing I had no choice but to do
was of course open it up so let's check
out the internal components here so to
open it it's actually super simple you
just press in here and then it slides
over and boom you're inside it's that
quick that's easier than my main
computer I wish I had a case like that
so inside were immediately greeted by
two of the most beautiful things you
have ever seen and that is to RTX 8000
GPUs as 48 gigabytes of vram per GPU
they're connected via an env link there
and that gives you a combined total of a
96 gigabytes of vram which is amazing so
for the rest of our internal goodies it
looks like quite a few of them are
hiding underneath this cover here I saw
the big red here it looks like a handle
I assumed I could pull it and sure
enough I got away with it and underneath
there there are the two Intel Xeon Gold
8 core CPUs as well as all of our RAM
which currently amounts to 192 gigabytes
of RAM which is also amazing so now to
geek out even more this cover is
actually more than just a cover
it's a molded piece which is serving to
actually channel the airflow coming off
of the fans coming off of the heat sinks
for the CPUs and it's actually kind of
interesting I've never seen anybody use
a cover over them to actually channel
the air and so as I was curious does
that actually work because if you've
ever played with air flow and
temperatures in computer cases then you
know it's actually a really tricky thing
to get right and it's really
easy to do something you think is
obvious and you're just totally wrong so
I was curious one does it actually help
these two CPUs in any way and then two
is it negatively impacting this GPU here
because the clearance it's like it's
really close it's less than a centimeter
of clearance between this GPU and the
wall of that cover and that cover is
moving hot air so the cover itself is
actually probably pretty hot too so so I
ran some tests and with the cover on
this CPU is actually five degrees
Celsius cooler than with it off this CPU
has no change this GPU has no change and
in this GPU has no change either but
this is our hot GPU and then this would
traditionally be our hot CPU because the
hot air from this CPU is blowing onto
the heatsink here and then it's blowing
here and blowing out so actually this
heatsink is taking on more heat than
this heatsink so this is typically going
to be your hotter CPU but it turns out
this is your hot CPU now so so yeah
anyway that's that's pretty impressive
so basically this molded piece saves
this 5 degrees Celsius under load so
that pretty much covers all of the
exciting hardware bits to the machine
but pretty much everything else is like
really quick and easy to like pop in and
out like all these fans that just slide
in and out also you've got the power
supply which is a pretty honkin PSU
this is a 1400 watts which is plenty of
power for what we're running here so
also pretty dang impressive
so in terms of dimensions and footprints
I wouldn't use these measurements for
actually like making hard space but just
in general the machine is about 24 and a
half inches long which translates to 62
ish centimeters tall
it's about seventeen and a half which
translates to forty four and a half
centimeters and width is about seven and
three-quarters inches which translates
to twenty centimeters so I mean
relatively it's a large machine you know
compared to your average computer but
all things considered what's in here
it's actually a pretty condensed case
and things aren't like squish next to
each other I'd say this case is about
the same volume wise if not smaller than
my main computer and has way more of a
punch so pretty cool there also
the machine itself is super heavy I
haven't actually weighed it but it's
very heavy and it comes with like these
carrying handles up at the top and at
the bottom I would never trust those
carrying handles though
I don't know who has the bravery to
trust those but it wasn't me yeah yeah
we get it it's amazing how much does it
cost so the machine as you see it fully
configured is thirty thousand dollars
and I know there will be people in the
comments who are like I could build that
for way cheaper too that I would say hey
maybe you should start a high-end
workstation company
I too could go to PC part picker and put
together something with similar specs
for less money at least to the point
that everything will connect and it will
boot up and that's where it starts so
I've been building computers now for
over a decade and one thing that I've
learned is one I don't know that much
about building computers even though
I've been doing it quiet for a long time
every time I build I learned something
new and I'm like oh yeah I didn't think
about that but finding things that just
simply connect and you turn on is a lot
different than finding parts that are
all very compatible with each other as
well as reliable and even like little
things like air flow like we were
talking about that takes a long time to
kind of figure out how to get right and
if you're going to be building or
getting spending this much money on hard
where you definitely want to get it
right and you want things to be as
optimal as possible so I I think it
would be fun to build it and if you're
someone who knows how to build machines
and this might not actually be for you
but even then you might seriously
consider it because you might also just
waste a bunch of your money and not get
as much for your money as you thought
you might be getting so anyway yeah so
so with that what else do you get so
when you buy this from Lenovo the other
thing that it comes with is a three year
warranty and if the three year warranty
is not good enough for a computer
equipment that is going to be running
very hot and up to 24/7 for three years
if you ask me that's a crazy warranty to
give because I've never built a machine
that I ran for like data science
purposes that runs even remotely close
to or at 24/7 times that has not failed
at least a part broken within I would
have to say at least the first year but
definitely within three years and again
I'm sure there will be people who were
like oh I've built my computer and it's
never had a problem for ten years well
there's a big difference between playing
a video game once a day for a few hours
and running something 24/7 that's really
hard on the parts heat is the biggest
thing it just kills so so anyway a
three-year warranty alone is pretty
awesome but that's not any three-year
warranty it's a three year next business
day on-site warranty they will send
someone out to you to repair your
machine so that's also pretty epic
so anyway overall I'm actually really
impressed with this I'm always nervous
about people sending me or offering to
send me equipment because especially
something like this like I said I'm
someone who builds my own machines so if
you're charging me a markup over
hardware I need to know why and at least
to me it seems like you know for
especially for like enterprise customers
or even like research if you're paying
out to AWS or something it just doesn't
take long to hit this price tag and
regardless of whether or not this
machine was even 40 thousand dollars
it's still gonna make sense to actually
own the hardware because like
AWS if you're running 24/7 after a month
of 96 gigs of VRAM you're looking at
like $13,000 that's on AWS that will be
the same on Azure because they basically
price match and then like on Google I
want to say you'd be looking at like
eleven thousand dollars or something
like that which is just nuts so so it
would not take very long to equal the
purchase price of this thing and then
you have it and then after that you've
you've you've made a solid investment so
if you or someone who's training big
models for long term then this is
definitely a machine for you so at least
for me as soon as I got this thing and
kind of poked around that same day
within hours of receiving the machine I
turned it on and I have been running
this machine non-stop since I got it
over a month ago and it's just been
nothing but a workhorse so some of the
things that I've done with it one is I
trained the self-driving car in the
Karla environment using reinforcement
learning and doing that on this machine
for example compared to like my main
machine I'm running a Titan or TX in my
main computer which actually has 24 gigs
of VRAM but on that main machine I was
only able to run basically one agent in
one environment on my main computer
whereas on here I was actually able to
run four environments and eight agents
and we actually could have run eight
environments and eight agents but we
were getting better FPS frames per
second on with the four environment so
we ended up just going that route but
that's pretty substantial that's eight
agents so basically we're training eight
times faster so you might even be
thinking well I don't need 96 gigs of
VRAM I'll just use 16 or something like
that and again if you're using just that
basic V 100 with 16 gigs of VRAM on AWS
this machine you're still gonna spend
the same amount of money right like
either you're running 96 gigs of VRAM
per hour or you're running 16 and if
you're running 16 it's gonna take you 6
times longer so it's still gonna even if
all you're doing is scaling out and
improving that way you're gonna probably
do better the next thing is just simply
being able to run
even like bigger models so another thing
that I was able to do on this machine
and that's what I'm training right now
is a deep learning chat bot which a
month besides just having it just a ton
of data right now even after like
pre-processing and throwing out just a
ton of data we've got 300 million
comment and reply pairs so it's a lot of
data to get through so it's nice to have
the most recent I mean the r-tx 8000 is
the best GPU you can get your hands on
right now only really made better if you
could maybe access like a TPU or
something like that but those are
unbelievably expensive so I'm not even
gonna really reference GPUs but anyway
basically this is the best GPU you can
get your hands on and so one it's just
quick it's quicker so even the r-tx
cards they're actually faster than the
v100 cards and so with the chatbot one
it's it's training faster it takes a
long time to get through all those
samples but then too I'm able to train a
huge model compared to the previous
models I've ever been able to train I've
only able or at least historically the
biggest one I've done is 11 gigabytes of
vram whereas here we're on 96 so the
model is way way larger so it's enabled
us to actually play it not only to train
things faster like sometimes up to like
8 times faster I'm also able to play
with much much bigger model so it's
really cool I've really grown to enjoy
the machine unfortunately I have to send
it back so so I don't know why they
won't let me keep it forever but such is
life
so anyway that about concludes the
overview of this this machine a little
bit ago I did a video on you know cloud
versus local computing and this is
basically like the pinnacle of local
hardware so if you're running like long
term training models and you're paying
out to a cloud provider over the course
of many months because it running 24/7
you should really consider something
local and at least for me I'm really
impressed with this machine it's it's
clear that Lenovo put thought into this
machine and its reliability and the last
thing I'll say too is that one of
asking about their warranty I was like
giving them examples of like what would
you do if someone can't do this and
there's and basically what what the guy
told me is that Lenovo over the course
of two years has a five percent repair
rate which means so this is someone he
actually like called in and needed
something to get repaired so five
percent over the course of two years
that's insane I mean it's just insane
I've never been able to build something
that hasn't actually had a failure
within that time frame so five percent
is incredibly low so as long as you're
having a three year on-site next
business day warranty it's in your best
interest and make stuff that doesn't
fail so that's also really cool you can
definitely have faith in the machine
also Lenovo as a company is highly
unlikely to not be here in three years
so you can actually have faith in the
actual warranties still actually being
useful in three years
so anyway really cool I'm actually super
impressed with the product I think it's
actually a good it's a fair price I know
thirty thousand sounds like a lot but
what you're getting in return I think is
worth it and even with my knowledge if I
was in the market for spending thirty
thousand dollars on local hardware I'd
still seriously consider this certainly
over cloud computing but also just in
general versus I'll say building it
myself just because I rather have some
tried and tested method for making use
of my might my my hugely expensive two
CPUs and GPUs I mean just the CPUs and
GPUs this is fifty five hundred fifty
five hundred I want to say that each CPU
might begin this wrong I want to say
like two thousand dollars looking for a
CPU it's a lot of money so if you're
gonna buy such high-end hardware it
would be nice if you could find a
configuration that's already tested and
stuff so anyway that's it for now until
next time
[Applause]